that i celebrate
is
the reverie
the
intoxication
the cognitive slip and slide the
disinhibition the jazz
of creative flow
creative flow
is musical creative flow
is improvisation creative flow
is the territory beyond the maps it's as
bodhi said in point break where you lose
yourself
and you find yourself
it's the zone it's the surfer
in the pocket as timothy leary said in
these moments your future is right in
front of you
your past is exploding behind you your
footprints are being washed from the
shore it's a non-depletive
non-extractive act done solely for the
pleasure of the act itself and that is
the destiny of man
i mean it feels almost like creative
flow gives us a glimpse of our god-like
possibilities abraham maslow the
positive psychology says we get a thrill
from the god-like possibilities we see
in ourselves in those moments when it
counts on the stage yet we
simultaneously shiver at those very same
possibilities
now i would argue that one of the things
i most enjoy when you and i
engage creatively is that you're so
free now i i don't even think it comes
from training it's just you're born with
this capacity like an actor to like let
go
right to just surrender
but that's not that's not easy for
people right most men lead lives of
quiet desperation people are in a state
of inhibition and anxiousness we're like
clenching all the time and it like
sometimes it just takes like a goddamn
onslaught an initiation a kind of leap
of faith and ego death a trust fall but
that kind of surrender is fundamentally
absurd it makes no sense to leap from
the abyss in a state of trust and grace
i mean that's the definition of paradox
it's insane but in some sense
surrendering our affordances is required
for self-transcendence and for actual
freedom the jazz musician in the pocket
has to have transcended himself at some
point like the end of the film whiplash
like there's gotta be a moment a life
and death psychological
in the blissful crucifixion where you
fully transcend yourself but
self-transcendence is also annihilation
quaking annihilating glory but it is
annihilation and as you know neurotic
people like me we fear death
and so we fumble and stumble trying to
transcend ourselves but mostly bringing
ourselves along kicking and screaming
that ego that just can't unclench and it
can't let go
and perhaps only in psycho psychedelic
visionary states can people experience
themselves without their own inhibiting
ego but others can find those spaces on
stages the artist in the pocket the jazz
musician in the zone the surfer catching
that wave my question to you is simply
this my friend
how do you so easily tap into that from
an
improvisational acting performance
standpoint because you do it well
sometimes i get there filming
you like i lose myself
i become self i try i self transcend
in when i'm recording something but
but when i'm actually
on camera there's it's a little bit
harder because the
self consciousness is in some sense
imposed you know duality is is imposed
by the camera now i am aware of how i'm
being seen but
the the real gift is when that jazz
musician can transcend himself in spite
of being observed the actor can
transcend himself in spite of the camera
being there that he can transport
himself so completely that he forgets
himself and he forgets the camera and he
believes that he is that character
and that that kind of exorcism that
self-possession that he's taken over we
call that a kind of madness but it's
also divine christian bale is a great
example of an actor that can so
self-transcend that can so lose himself
method actors are the same that it is a
kind of cultivated
steering of a schizoid kind of
self-separation you get past yourself to
connect to something deeper in yourself
and
that
watching that is just
it's
wondrous when we see actors do it it's
incredible when we see surfers do it i
think all of them would say man i don't
remember what i did i don't remember i
wasn't there and that's just incredible
so what do you think about that
because it seems easy for you i'm
struggling i'm always struggling